I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Oh, hi.
Lady, I have a new way I'm being influenced.
我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是“办公室女郎 6.0”。哦，嗨。女郎，我最近有了新的受影响方式。
I'm being influenced into making my bed a very specific way.
Like different than how you've been.
made it your whole life? Different than how I've been making it. Yeah, I like a made bed because at night
I like to get into a bed that's made. Listen, I like a made bed because then I feel like my room doesn't
feel cluttered. Same. I can have maybe like a pile of clothes I need to put away, but if my bed is made,
I don't feel so, you know, sloppy. Same. Well, I got influenced. I saw this video, this guy making
his bed. He's very certain about how it should be made. Okay. And I love it so much that.
I'm making my kids' beds again.
我最近被影响得开始以一种非常具体的方式铺床。就像跟你以前铺得完全不一样？跟我一辈子的铺床方式都不一样。对，我喜欢铺好的床，因为晚上我喜欢钻进一张铺好的床里。听着，我喜欢铺好的床，因为那样我觉得我的房间看起来不会杂乱。同感。我可能有一堆需要收起来的衣服，但如果我的床铺好了，我就不会觉得那么，你知道的，邋遢。同感。好吧，我被影响了。我看到这个视频，有个家伙在铺床。他非常确信床应该怎么铺。好吧。我太喜欢了，以至于我又开始给孩子们铺床了。
I'm making all the beds.
I make beds like on the weekends.
Like on a week morning, everyone's like running out.
I'm like, ah.
No, I'm so excited to make beds now.
Can I ask, how were you influenced to make your bed differently?
I'll share the video with you.
I would love it.
我在铺所有的床。我周末会铺床。比如在工作日的早晨，每个人都在匆忙往外跑。我就想，啊。不，我现在铺床可兴奋了。请问，你是怎么被影响得以不同方式铺床的？我会把视频分享给你。我很乐意。
I'll share it with everyone.
I'm huge into making my bed.
He's delightful.
So first of all, I would always sort of pull the comforter all the way up and then put the
pillows on top of it.
That's like a hard no for him.
He's like, no.
You bend back the comforter to let the sheets breathe underneath.
我会分享给每一个人。我超级喜欢铺床。他太可爱了。所以首先，我以前总是会把羽绒被一直拉上去，然后把枕头放在它上面。这对他来说是绝对不行的。他会说，不行。你要把羽绒被往下折叠，让被单在下面透气。
And then also you don't put your pillows vertical.
You put them horizontal.
Like a hotel.
Yes.
It kind of is like a hotel bed.
And he has strong feelings about throw pillows.
I bet he doesn't like them because he wants all the pillows flat.
I bet there's no throw pillows on his bed.
然后还有，你不能把枕头竖着放。你要横着放。像酒店那样。对。确实有点像酒店的床。而且他对靠枕有强烈的看法。我敢打赌他不喜欢靠枕，因为他想让所有的枕头都平放。我敢说他的床上没有靠枕。
You can have one long lumbar pillow sitting in front of your four stacked pillows, the end.
So my two hummingbird pillows are off the bed, huh?
I mean...
They didn't make the cut.
Wow.
Sorry.
Well, you know what, fella?
你可以在四个叠放的枕头前面放一个长腰枕，就这样。所以我的两个蜂鸟枕头得从床上拿下来，是吗？我是说……它们没入选。哇。抱歉。哇。好吧，你知道吗，老兄？
You don't get to tell me.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my goodness.
Don't come between me and my hummingbird pillows that my mom got at Cracker Barrel.
Well, I want to share with everyone that you had a little bit of a Pam moment this week at work.
What?
Oh, no.
You're going to tell people about that?
你管不着我。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。别挡在我和我妈在Cracker Barrel买的蜂鸟枕头之间。好吧，我要跟每个人分享，你这周在工作中有了一个小小的“帕姆时刻”。什么？哦，不。你打算把这事告诉大家吗？
Sam.
Um, go, go nuts.
Did someone in this office make a sign and hung it over the sink?
It is eerily similar to the sign of the show.
This one might be more passive aggressive.
So Jenna got here before me.
I come in and she's just like writing something and then she's taping it.
And I'm like, what is happening?
萨姆。嗯，随便说吧。这办公室里是不是有人做了一个标牌，挂在水槽上方？它和剧里的标牌惊人地相似。这个可能更具被动攻击性。所以珍娜比我先到这。我进来时她正在写什么东西，然后她拿胶带把它贴起来。我就想，发生什么事了？
And Sam's like, well, go read the sign.
Sam, will you read it?
It says, please wash your own dishes.
Dishwashing service is not provided here.
Because we share this space.
Yes, we do.
With other podcasts and people recording things.
And I keep coming in and the sink is just full of people's dirty cups and dishes.
萨姆就说，去读读那个标牌。萨姆，你能读一下吗？上面写着：请清洗您自己的餐具。这里不提供洗碗服务。因为我们共享这个空间。是的，我们确实共享。还有其他播客和录音的人。我一直进来，结果水槽里全都是别人用脏的杯子和盘子。
And we should say, you guys, at the end of our recording day, we clean anything in the sink that was ours.
And we clean the studio.
Yeah.
We tidy up.
Well, I think there's some new people recording here.
We don't know who they are.
It's not Ben Stiller and Adam Scott.
我们得说，伙计们，在我们录音日结束时，我们会清洗水槽里属于我们的任何东西，我们还会打扫录音室。对。我们收拾干净。好吧，我想这里有一些录音的新人。我们不知道他们是谁。我们不知道他们是谁。又不是本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）和亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）。
I want to say there were never dishes in the sink.
when they were here. Yeah, really big headset settings, but no dishes. But whoever has been coming in,
I think they might have assumed that maybe that's part of the custodial service. And you're letting
them know. I'm letting them know. It is not. I'm tired of washing your shit. I'm going to take a
picture of you by it. Can I give you a quick update on the situation? Sure. Yeah, Matt.
So I've let our landlords and people who manage the building know about the situation. And there's a
full-on investigation.
Stop it.
我想说，当他们在这里时，水槽里从来没有过盘子。对，真的很大牌，但没有盘子。但不管是谁一直在来，我想他们可能以为这也许是保洁服务的一部分。而你在让他们知道。我在让他们知道。并不是。我厌倦了洗你们的破盘子。我要在它旁边给你拍张照。能让我向你简单汇报一下目前的情况吗？当然。可以，马特。所以我已经把这种情况告知了我们的房东和物业管理人员。现在正在进行全面调查。别开玩笑了。
Possibly involving security footage of who might be there.
There's an investigation underway.
Oh, my, Matt.
I need closure on this now.
Into who is leaving the dishes in the sink?
This is your first mom detective case with an actual result.
This is not yet.
Not yet.
可能还涉及谁可能在那里的安全监控录像。调查正在进行中。哦，天哪，马特。我这下非得弄个水落石出不可。查看到底是谁把盘子留在水槽里的？这是你第一个有实际结果的“妈妈侦探”案件。现在还没有。还没有。
True.
Wow.
Wait, so now I'm so baffled.
Are there cameras in our kitchen?
I think just in the building hall,
ways.
Oh.
Not that, I mean, you guys, I haven't done anything in the kitchen.
真的。哇。等等，那我太迷惑了。我们厨房里有摄像头吗？我想只是在大楼走廊里有。哦。倒不是说，我是说，伙计们，我可没在厨房里干过什么。
I'm just saying, well, we did change clothes in there.
We have changed clothes in the offices here.
I know.
Like, you'll have a meeting and we'll change clothes before we, like, hop on the Zoom.
Exactly.
Building security footage.
Okay, good.
So, okay, this is interesting.
我只是说，嗯，我们在里面换过衣服。我们确实在这里的办公室里换过衣服。我知道。比如，你开完会，我们在连线Zoom之前会换衣服。正是如此。大楼监控录像。好吧，很好。所以，好吧，这很有趣。
So they are looking at the date of the dirty dishes from probably last week when I was annoyed.
and I sent something.
Who was in the hallway and who went in.
They are.
We got our best people on it.
Wow.
I had no idea.
所以他们正在查看脏盘子的日期，大概是上周我感到恼火的时候，我发了些东西。谁在走廊里，谁进去了。他们正在查。他们正在查。我们派了最优秀的人去处理。哇。我真不知道。
I just thought, Matt, you just fired off a snarky email like, hey, clean your tissues.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
Well, yeah.
Okay, so, Jenna, you have a tidy bed and we're going to have a tidy office.
Where are we?
That was a lot of banter.
It was.
我只是以为，马特，你只是随手发了一封尖酸刻薄的邮件，比如，嘿，清理你们的纸巾。哦，天哪。好吧，好吧。所以，珍娜，你有一张整洁的床，我们也会有一个整洁的办公室。我们说到哪了？刚才扯了好多闲话。确实。
Up top, but we're in a bantering mood.
We have a really fun episode today, though.
With a great guest.
Yes.
we got to interview Robin Lynch, who played the CPR instructor in Stress Relief Part 1.
So in our original breakdown of the episode, we had shared that we tried to get a hold of her
and we wanted to speak with her. Well, after that episode aired, we got a message from Robin
thanking us for our kind words about her performance. And she was like, I would love to come
一开始就扯远了，不过我们现在很喜欢闲聊。不过我们今天有一集非常有趣的节目。还有一位很棒的嘉宾。对，我们采访了罗宾·林奇（Robin Lynch），她在《减压》（上）中饰演了心肺复苏（CPR）教练。所以在我们最初对这集的剖析中，我们曾分享过我们试图联系她，并且很想和她聊聊。好吧，在那集播出后，我们收到了罗宾发来的信息，感谢我们对她表演的美好评价。她说，我很乐意来。
and share about my experience on the show. So listen, this was a really fun chat. She is such a
lovely person. You might remember that I suspected she had some sort of actual CPR experience because
she was so real. And in our interview, Robin will reveal if I was right. But first, we have our
chit-chat suggestion from Leanne P in Cleveland, Ohio. Hi, office ladies. My name is Leanne and I'm
from Cleveland, Ohio. I am a history buff and often wonder what it would have been like to
witness certain events. This is especially true when I visit the Gettysburg battlefield.
My chit-chat question is this.
If you could be a fly on the wall and witness any event in history, what would you choose?
分享我在剧中的经历。所以听着，这次聊天真的非常有趣。她是一个非常可爱的人。你可能还记得，我曾怀疑她有过某种实际的CPR经验，因为她演得太逼真了。在我们的采访中，罗宾将揭晓我是否猜对了。但首先，我们要宣读来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰的利安·P（Leanne P）的闲聊建议。嗨，办公室女郎们。我叫利安，来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰。我是一个历史迷，经常想知道亲历某些历史事件会是什么感觉。当我参观葛底斯堡战场时，这种感觉尤其强烈。我的闲聊问题是：如果你能成为墙上一只苍蝇，亲历历史上的任何事件，你会选择什么？
It could be a major event or something small that has always fascinated you.
Looking forward to your answer.
Did you have something come to mind right away?
I had something that came to my mind immediately.
Like two things actually.
Okay.
Can I share both?
Of course.
它可以是一件重大事件，也可以是一直令你着迷的小事。期待你们的回答。你们脑海里有没有立刻浮现出什么？我脑海里立刻就浮现出了一点东西。实际上是两件事。好的。我能两件都分享吗？当然。
Okay.
So the first one, you guys, is years ago, I was in London and I did a tour of the Hampton Court
Palace. And on this tour, I was not expecting this. I sort of thought I would see like old rooms and,
you know, like ye oldy things. We turn this corner and we enter into what looks like a very small
tennis court. Oh, I've seen it. I've been there. Yes, right? It's indoors. It's indoors. It was built
in the 1520s. I guess it still remains active today and you can play on it if you remember.
There were two guys playing tennis.
When you were there?
好的。所以第一件，伙计们，是多年前我在伦敦时，我去参观了汉普顿宫。在这个参观过程中，我完全没有料到这一点。我原本以为我会看到一些古老的房间，你知道的，诸如此类的古老事物。我们转过这个拐角，进入了一个看起来非常像小型网球场的地方。哦，我见过。我去过那里。对吧？是室内的。是室内的。它建于1520年代。我想它现在仍然在使用，如果你预约的话还可以在上面打球。当时有两个人在打球。你在那的时候？
Yes.
Oh, no one was playing when I was there.
Well, anyway, I guess the history says that Henry the 8th was an avid and very skilled player of what they called real tennis, which was often called the Sport of Kings.
It was the precursor to what we know now as modern tennis.
And I just would love to just be a fly on the wall watching Henry the 8th in his whatever, his whole royal court playing this game.
that would be fascinating to me.
Very cool.
Right?
对。哦，我那会儿没人打球。好吧，无论如何，据历史记载，亨利八世是他们所谓的“皇家网球”（real tennis）的热情且非常熟练的玩家，这种运动通常被称为“国王的运动”。它是我们现在所知的现代网球的前身。我真的很想变成墙上一只苍蝇，看着亨利八世和他的什么人，他的整个皇家宫廷在玩这个游戏。那对我来说会太迷人了。太酷了。对吧？
So obviously that's driven by my love of tennis and just wanting to see what that game looked like in the 1520s.
But then the other thing I've always sort of, I don't know if the word romanticize is right,
but I've just always thought it would have been so cool to witness the very first moon landing
and walking on the moon.
Like, I can't imagine the electricity
that was going through our country at that time
and the excitement and how collectively
everyone came together to watch and witness this moment.
所以这显然是由我对网球的热爱以及仅仅想看看1520年代那种游戏是什么样子的愿望所驱动的。但除此之外，我一直觉得——我不知道浪漫化这个词是否准确——但我一直觉得亲眼见证人类历史上第一次登月和在月球上行走会是一件超级酷的事情。真的，我无法想象当时我们国家洋溢着的电光石火般的激情、兴奋感，以及所有人如何齐心协力地观看和见证这一时刻。
You know, people gathered around their televisions
and the feeling that felt like
to see that moment in history,
I think would be so amazing to see in real time.
You know, you can see old footage of it,
but to be at home with your family,
watching your little home TV of that event must have just been so amazing.
Yeah.
你知道，人们聚集在电视机周围，亲眼看到那一历史时刻的感觉，我认为实时看到它会是如此不可思议。你知道，你可以看到它的旧录像，但能和家人呆在家里的电视机前观看那一事件，一定太神奇了。对。
So those were the two that came to mind.
I mean, you know, there's so many.
It's hard to pick, you know, but Leanne, I loved this question.
Well, it's interesting.
I thought about the moon landing as well.
Did you really?
I did because I thought how there are some things that when they're happening,
you know they are historic, and that's an example of one.
所以这两件是我脑海中最先浮现的。我是说，你知道，有太多了。很难挑选，你知道的，但是利安，我很喜欢这个问题。好吧，这很有趣。我也想过登月。真的吗？是的，因为我想，有些事情在发生时，你就知道它们是历史性的，这就是一个例子。
Yes.
And then there's other things that only,
later, you realize.
You sort of realize, oh, that was a historic moment.
But if you were there, it might not feel any different than just a regular moment.
But I got really caught up.
Like my first thought was that I thought of all like the unsolved crimes.
And I thought, oh, what if I could be there to see what really happened?
是的。然后还有另一些事情，只有在事后，你才会意识到。你才会恍然大悟，哦，那是个历史性时刻。但如果你当时身处其中，它可能感觉跟任何普通时刻没什么两样。但我真的很纠结。就像我的第一反应是我想到了所有那些未破的悬案。我想，哦，要是我能在现场看看真正发生了什么就好了？
And then I would just know.
Like I could just, not that I want to see a crime.
Oh, my goodness.
But, you know, like, then we'd have, like, certainty.
Mm-hmm.
Right?
Yeah.
But then I don't really want to see a crime happen because that feels disturbing and upsetting.
然后我就能直接知道了。就像我可以——倒不是说我想去看犯罪现场。哦，天哪。但是，你知道的，那样我们就能有确定性了。嗯哼。对吧？是的。但后来我又觉得，我其实并不想看到犯罪发生，因为那感觉挺让人不安和心烦的。
You don't want to see the crime.
You want to see who did it.
Yeah.
I want to end the mystery.
Like whoever's leaving the, you're like, ah, it was you.
We knew it.
And we were right all along.
Or like, oh, my gosh, they really were innocent or whatever.
你不想看犯罪过程。你想看是谁干的。对。我想终结这个谜团。就像不管是谁在留那些，你就会想，啊，原来是你。我们早就知道了。而且我们一直都是对的。或者，天哪，他们真的是无辜的，诸如此类的。
Or mystery solved.
This is very much your brain of, like,
Your brain likes to finish an equation, solve a problem, put that last piece in the puzzle.
I guess I thought, like, I did think, how could it be useful to more than just myself?
Mom detectives of history.
Oh.
I guess so.
或者谜题解开。这非常符合你的大脑模式，比如，你的大脑喜欢完成一个方程式，解决一个问题，把最后一块拼图拼上。我想，我确实在想，这怎么能不仅仅对自己有用呢？历史的妈妈侦探。哦。我想是的。我想是的。
We go back and solve all the crimes of the past.
Yes, with snacks.
You could go back to two weeks ago and see who was in our kitchen.
Ah, yes.
Exactly.
But then I was like, okay, since I don't really want to witness an actual crime that feels upsetting, I googled.
I was a lady who Googles.
我们回到过去，解开过去所有的谜案。是的，带着零食。你可以回到两周前，看看谁在我们的厨房里。啊，是的。完全正确。但后来我想，好吧，既然我真的不想目睹真实的犯罪，那感觉挺让人心烦的，于是我谷歌了一下。我是一个会谷歌的女士。
And I was like, what are some historical events that would be cool to witness?
It's literally what I put in.
And you know what popped up that I was like, yeah?
And it's a little bit in the same vein is the construction of the pyramids.
Oh, yes.
Because like, wouldn't you like to be like, that's how they did it?
Yeah.
Well, aliens.
我就想，有什么历史事件是亲历起来会很酷的？这真的是我输入的内容。你知道弹出了什么让我觉得“对哦”的答案吗？它和金字塔的建造有异曲同工之妙。哦，对呀。因为，难道你不想去看看“哦，原来他们是这么干的”吗？对。好吧，外星人。
Well, I could answer that question for you because I will have seen it.
Sam, what about you?
I, okay, my brain went to where your brain went.
It went to like Black Dahlia or Jack the Ripper.
But in the same thing, I don't want to see those murders happen.
So I landed on, do you guys know who D.B. Cooper is?
I did not.
D.B. Cooper was the alias that he gave to the FBI.
好吧，我可以为你解答这个问题，因为我到时候已经亲眼看见了。萨姆，你呢？我，好吧，我的脑回路跟你的一样。我想到了黑色大丽花或开膛手杰克。但同样道理，我不想看到那些谋杀案发生。所以我最终想到的是，你们知道DB·库珀（D.B. Cooper）是谁吗？我不知道。DB·库珀是他在给联邦调查局（FBI）时使用的化名。
So in November 24, 1971, a guy named D.B. Cooper hijacked a Northwest Orient flight,
demanded a $200,000 ransom and parachuted from the plane into a heavily wooded area of South Washington.
Experts highly doubt he survived the freezing temperatures and high-speed winds, but in 1980,
a young boy discovered a decaying package containing $5,800 of the ransom money buried along the
Columbia River.
So I would just be curious who that guy was.
Like, where if he made it?
Did he make it or did someone find his dead body and the money?
所以1971年11月24日，一个名叫DB·库珀的家伙劫持了一架西北东方航空公司的航班，索要20万美元的赎金，然后从飞机上跳伞降落在华盛顿南部一片树木繁茂的区域。专家高度怀疑他在严寒和高速风中生还的可能，但在1980年，一个小男孩在哥伦比亚河沿岸发现了一个腐烂的包裹，里面装着5800美元沿途埋藏的赎金。所以我只是好奇那家伙到底是谁。比如，他到底成功了吗？他成功逃脱了，还是有人找到了他的尸体和钱？
Exactly.
Or did he leave some of the money out so that?
that he would appear dead.
Oh.
Yeah.
You guys both want a mom detective history.
I think I just want to time travel is what I want to use this for.
I want to time travel and play tennis.
没错。或者他是不是故意留下一部分钱，好让人以为他已经死了？哦。是的。你们俩都想要一个“妈妈侦探”历史版。我想我只是想进行时间旅行，这就是我想用这个能力做的事。我想进行时间旅行去打网球。
Yeah.
Also,
I'm laughing so hard at the idea of you backhanding,
was it King Henry the 8th in the face,
but you hulking out on a living king.
Oh, my gosh.
I would be sent to the tower.
Yeah, exactly.
对。还有，一想到你反手一拍，把——是亨利八世国王吧——打脸上的画面，我就笑得不行，你居然对一个活着的国王大打出手。哦，天哪。我会被关进塔里的。对，没错。
A little angela.
Yeah.
If I could beheaded afterwards.
I know.
I'd be like, sorry.
Yeah.
You shouldn't have been in the way.
Do you do your racket up, Henry the 8th?
一个小安吉拉。对。如果我事后被砍头的话。我懂。我会说，对不起。对。你不该挡路的。你把球拍拿起来了吗，亨利八世？
Leg kick.
It's too funny.
Matt, what about you?
Do you have one?
Yeah, so I love American history.
So, like, kind of my first thoughts are, like, something kind of rugged.
Like, I've always loved the Revolutionary War or, like, the Gold Rush.
But then I sort of think, like, it sounds kind of, like, hard and cold, and, like, most people
踢腿。太搞笑了。马特，你呢？你有一个吗？是的，我喜欢美国历史。所以，就像，我的第一反应是，某种比较粗犷的东西。比如，我一直很喜欢独立战争，或者淘金热。但随后我又想，听起来有点，艰难和冰冷，而且，大多数人
aren't brushing their teeth at that time and just, like, sounds a little too rugged for me.
The Gold Rush is too rugged.
Yeah, I kind of just want to go to a swing in good time, like Paris before the war or the summer of love or something like that.
Oh, yeah.
You know, I'm just here for the vibes.
Oh, my God.
If I could be at the Green Day concert with the mud fight, that would be like so epic.
Yeah, those would suck 94.
在那个时候都不刷牙，而且，听起来对我来说有点太粗犷了。淘金热太粗犷了。对，我只想去一个轻松美好的时代，比如战前的巴黎或者爱之夏之类的。哦，对。你知道，我只是为了氛围而去的。哦，天哪。如果我能在那个有泥浆大战的绿日（Green Day）演唱会上，那一定会太史诗级了。对，那应该是在94年。
Yeah.
Or like I think about too that that amazing concert with Queen.
Was it Live Aid where it was that massive stadium?
That just felt like election.
electric, didn't it? Yeah. Yeah. That was another one where everyone, no matter where you were,
was at your TV set, like the moon landing. Yeah, yeah. I mean, partially for me, for the moon landing.
Okay, cool, science, yay. But also, you know, I'd have a really cute outfit. Yeah. And along those
对。对。或者我想到了皇后乐队（Queen）那场令人惊叹的演唱会。是那个巨大的体育场的“拯救生命”（Live Aid）演唱会吗？那感觉太有活力了，不是吗？对，对。这也是那种无论你在哪里，每个人都守在电视机前，就像登月一样。对，对。我的意思是，对，对我来说部分是为了登月。好吧，酷，科学，耶。但也因为，你知道，我会穿一套超级可爱的衣服。对。顺着这个
same vines, I'll say Beatles playing Ed Sullivan would be pretty... Oh, that'd be amazing. Their first time in
America would be pretty great. All right. Yay. Yay. So fun. Well, we're going to solve some mysteries and have
some fun, listen to music and play tennis when we go back in time. Thank you so much.
Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we are going to talk about a few of
the extra things that were added back to Stress Relief Part 1 from the Superfan episode. And
we are going to talk with Robin Lynch, who played Rose, the CPR instructor.
And you all know that the CPR training from Season 5 Stress Relief Part 1, it's epic. We all know this
scene. It's after Dwight's crazy fire drill, Stanley collapses, and now Michael is called everyone
思路，我会说披头士乐队（Beatles）在埃德·沙利文秀（Ed Sullivan）上的表演会相当……哦，那会太棒了。他们第一次来美国会相当不错。好吧。耶。耶。太有趣了。好吧，我们要去解开一些谜团，找点乐子，听听音乐，在我们回到过去时打打网球。非常感谢。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，我们将讨论一些从超级粉丝版中被加回到《减压》（上）中的额外内容。我们还将与饰演罗丝——CPR教练的罗宾·林奇进行对话。大家都知道第五季《减压》（上）中的CPR培训，简直太史诗级了。我们都知道这一幕。那是吉姆的疯狂消防演习之后，斯坦利晕倒了，现在迈克尔把所有人叫到
into the conference room to get CPR training. Should Stanley's heart, quote, go berserk again?
Every time Michael said Stanley's heart, well, it went berserk. It makes me laugh. So the superfan
version of this episode is fantastic. Way to go. Dave Rogers. And there's a ton of extra stuff
just from the CPR scenes that was put back in. For example, the moment we first meet Rose,
in the conference room is much longer,
and she and Michael will really get into it right from the beginning.
Rose kind of makes a joke and people laugh a little,
and Michael does not like it.
会议室里接受CPR培训。如果斯坦利的心脏“彻底失控”的话。每次迈克尔说斯坦利的心脏，它就彻底失控了。这让我大笑。所以这一集的超级粉丝版太棒了。干得好，戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）。光是从CPR场景中就有很多被加回来的额外内容。例如，我们在会议室里第一次见到罗丝的那个镜头要长得多，她和迈克尔从一开始就真正杠上了。罗丝开了个玩笑，大家笑了一小会儿，而迈克尔不喜欢这样。
He never likes that.
Let's hear it.
ABC, okay?
And that stands for airway, breathing, and circulation.
Okay, you know what, that could be a little confusing
because in sales, ABC means always be closing.
Well, try not to close the sale when administering CPR.
Okay, well, um,
他从来不喜欢这样。我们听听看。ABC，好吗？这代表气道、呼吸和循环。好吧，你知道，这可能会有点混乱，因为在销售中，ABC意味着“永远成交”（Always Be Closing）。好吧，在实施CPR时尽量不要去敲定销售。好吧，嗯，
Rose is it? This is serious and you're sort of making a mockery of it. We almost lost one of our employees and I feel like you're being a little jerky and a little condescending and sort of a tool.
Okay, I'm here to do a job and you cannot talk to me that way.
Well, honestly, the only reason that you are here, Rose, is because I couldn't get a CPR dummy.
So if you want to wander around for an hour, that's...
This is a farce. I should be teaching this course. Shut it, shut it.
Yeah, so Michael then has this talking head where he explains, like, he tried to get a CPR dummy by itself, but they insist that an instructor come with it. It's so amazing. But I love Rose, is it?
I also love, you know what, and you're kind of being a tool.
Can you imagine someone saying that to you if you've just like come to do this demonstration at an office? It's crazy.
你是罗丝吧？这很严肃，而你却在某种程度上对它进行嘲弄。我们差点失去了一位员工，我觉得你有点混蛋，有点居高临下，还有点像个二百五。好吧，我是来工作的，你不能那样跟我说话。好吧，老实说，罗丝，你来这里的唯一原因是因为我弄不到一个CPR假人。所以如果你想闲逛一个小时，那是……这是一场闹剧。这门课应该由我来教。闭嘴，闭嘴。是的，所以迈克尔随后有一个采访镜头，他解释说，他曾试图单独弄到一个CPR假人，但他们坚持要求必须有一名教练随行。这太神奇了。但我喜欢“你是罗丝吧？”我还喜欢，你知道的，“你有点像个二百五”。你能想象如果有人来办公室做演示，你对他说这样的话吗？这太疯狂了。
So next up, we see Kevin, and he's administering chest compressions to the dummy.
But in the superfan version, there's more bickering between Michael and Rose and Dwight gets in on it, too.
You have to hear it.
Rose, I am sorry.
It is just that Stanley Hudson here almost died.
We almost lost him.
And we need you to take this very seriously.
I am taking this seriously.
接下来，我们看到凯文正在对假人进行胸外按压。但在超级粉丝版中，迈克尔和罗丝之间有更多的斗嘴，德怀特也加入了进来。你得听听这个。罗丝，我很抱歉。只是这里的斯坦利·哈德森差点死了。我们差点失去他。我们需要你非常严肃对待这件事。我很严肃。
All right.
Well, then no more jokes, please.
Anyway, the first thing you need to do is assess the situation.
You can ask, are you okay?
Really?
He's had a heart attack, and you're going to make idle chit-chat?
Are you even certified?
Shut it, Dwight.
好吧，那就请不要再开玩笑了。无论如何，你需要做的第一件事是评估情况。你可以问，你还好吗？真的吗？他心脏病发作了，而你还要去闲聊？你甚至有证书吗？闭嘴，德怀特。
Okay.
So there you go.
She has her hands full with these guys.
For sure.
And it's only going to get worse.
So now we have this bit where Michael is trying to convince Stanley to try administering CPR to the dummy.
And Stanley is not interested.
And this is when Michael has that great line where he says,
好吧。所以你看。她应付这群人真是焦头烂额。肯定的。而且情况只会更糟。现在我们有这样一个片段，迈克尔试图说服斯坦利尝试对假人进行CPR。而斯坦利对此毫无兴趣。就在这时，迈克尔说出了那句绝妙的台词，他说，
we're not always going to be there to coddle your heart back
when it disappears to be working.
What are you going to do if you are by yourself and your heart stops?
And Stanley says, I would die.
And Michael says, and you're okay with that?
And Stanley says, I'm okay with the logic of it.
I've always loved that exchange.
Me too.
当你的心脏消失不见、不再工作时，我们不可能总是在那里帮你把心哄回来。如果你独自一人，你的心脏停止了跳动，你该怎么办？斯坦利说，我会死。迈克尔说，你觉得这样可以吗？斯坦利说，我觉得这符合逻辑。我一直很喜欢这段对话。我也是。
Such a great scene.
And Leslie, like, his delivery is perfect.
Well, lady, when I was rewatching it, this whole exchange, it happens in front of Andy, Oscar, Phyllis, and Meredith.
They are like lined up in chairs along the wall. Michael is on his knees in front of Stanley in the wheelchair.
And I just have to encourage people to watch those four actors in the background during this exchange.
It is such an amazing, just deadpan, active listening work that they are doing.
nobody steals focus, but everyone is completely dialed in, engaged.
They're in character.
太棒的一幕了。而且莱斯利（Leslie）的台词交付堪称完美。好吧，女郎，当我重看时，整段对话都是在安迪、奥斯卡、菲利斯和梅雷迪思面前发生的。他们就像一排坐在墙边的椅子上。迈克尔跪在坐在轮椅上的斯坦利面前。我不得不鼓励大家在这段对话中去看看背景里的那四个演员。他们那呆滞、积极倾听的演技简直太棒了。没有人抢镜头，但所有人都完全沉浸其中，全神贯注。他们完全进入了角色。
I think it's a top tier background acting moment on the show.
I'm for sure going to check it out because I remember desperately wanting to be on the back row
and they put me right in the front.
And I'm almost never in the front.
And I was like, today of all days, where this is happening right there, I'm in the front.
I was like, oh, no, I was so.
worried I was going to break. Okay, well, so Michael does end up convincing Stanley to try CPR,
but he's going to bail pretty quickly. And Michael has to take over. And Rose says, okay,
我认为这是剧中顶级水准的背景表演时刻。我一定要去看看，因为我记得我当时拼命想坐在最后一排，结果他们把我安排在了最前面。我几乎从来不在前排。我想，偏偏是今天，正当这一切就在眼前发生时，我在前排。我就想，哦，不，我太担心自己会笑场了。好吧，所以迈克尔最终确实说服了斯坦利尝试CPR，但他很快就要退缩了。迈克尔不得不接手。罗丝说，好吧，
assessing the situation, are they breathing? And Michael says, no, Rose, they are not breathing,
but Steve is Michael says it's so snarky. So snarky. And then he says, and they have no arms or
legs. And Rose replies, that's not part of it.
So this obsession with what happened to the dummies, arms, and legs is much longer in the superfan version.
Like Michael and Dwight get very preoccupied with also like, what is the location of this person?
Where were they found?
And, you know, Rose is trying to be like, you're in an office, but it goes all over the place.
You have to hear it.
评估情况，他们在呼吸吗？迈克尔说，不，罗丝，他们没有呼吸，但是史蒂夫……迈克尔说话的语气太讽刺了。太讽刺了。然后他说，而且他们没有胳膊或腿。罗丝回答说，那不属于流程。所以这种对假人胳膊和腿去哪了的执念，在超级粉丝版中要长得多。比如迈克尔和德怀特对诸如此类的问题变得非常全神贯注：这个人的所在地在哪里？他们是在哪里被发现的？而且，你知道，罗丝试图表现得像“你们在办公室里”，但话题扯得越来越远。你必须听听这个。
You know what?
If we come across somebody with no arms or legs, do we bother resuscitating them?
I mean, what kind of quality of life do we have there?
I would want to live with no legs.
How about no arms?
No arms or legs is basically how you exist right now, Kevin.
You don't do anything.
Here's another question.
你知道吗？如果我们遇到一个没有胳膊或腿的人，我们还有必要对他们进行心肺复苏吗？我的意思是，我们在那里能有什么生活质量？我才不想没有双腿活着呢。没有胳膊怎么样？没有胳膊或腿基本上就是你现在的生存状态，凯文。你什么都不做。还有一个问题。
Was he born this way with no arms or legs?
Or were they blown off?
If that's the case, should we use a tourniquet to tie off the bloody stumps?
Okay, we're not going to be covering turnicets today just because that rarely happens in an office place?
Not covering turniquets?
That should be the first thing we cover.
Otherwise, the blood will just go.
oozing out of the stumps.
他是天生没有胳膊或腿的吗？还是被炸飞的？如果是这样，我们应该用止血带把流血的残端扎紧吗？好吧，我们今天不讨论止血带，因为这在办公室里很少发生？不讨论止血带？那应该是我们首先要讨论的东西。否则血就会从断肢残端汩汩流出来了。
I think Dwight is right.
Okay, this is the scenario.
This is a battlefield and there are bodies all over the place and some have had heart
attacks and other people are just resting.
So I think in that case, to go up to someone and say, are you okay?
That makes sense to me.
Okay, for the sake of argument, we are now at a battlefield and I think it's okay to
ask somebody if that's okay even in an office.
我觉得德怀特是对的。好吧，这是情境。这是一个战场，到处都是尸体，有些人心脏病发作了，而另一个人只是在休息。所以我想在这种情况下，走到某个人面前说，你还好吗？这对我来说说得通。好吧，为了争论起见，我们现在在一个战场上，我认为即使在办公室里，问某个人是否还好也是可以的。
And now who would like to come up and care for the job?
You know what, I'm already here.
I'll do it.
Okay.
So I'm walking across the battlefield.
There's someone.
Are they a heart attack victim or are they resting?
Are you okay?
现在谁想上来接手这项工作？你知道吗，我已经在这了。我来吧。好的。所以我正走过战场。有个人。他们是心脏病发作的受害者，还是他们只是在休息？你还好吗？
Oh my God!
Your arms and legs have been blown off.
I mean, it's just he can't focus.
He can't.
It's not about CPR at all now.
He's like reenacting some battlefield moment.
I really don't know how Robin got through it.
Also, you know, just being on set for the first time and now you're in front of the whole
天哪！你的胳膊和腿都被炸飞了。我的意思是，这简直……他根本无法专心。他做不到。现在这根本不是关于CPR了。他就像在重现某个战场时刻。我真的不知道罗宾是怎么坚持下来的。还有，你知道，第一次来到片场，现在你站在全体
entire group and she's driving the scene. It's just amazing. And so ultimately, this training ends
with Rose suggesting that Michael do chest compressions to the tune of staying alive.
And this quickly turns into a full-on dance party. Yes, the whole scene is amazing. It's so funny.
I think it's time that we talk to Robin about it. So here is the interview we had with Robin Lynch,
who plays Rose, the CPR instructor.
Hey, guys. Office ladies.
we're so happy to have you here.
Oh, you look just the same.
演员面前，而她在推动整场戏。这太神奇了。所以最终，这场培训以罗丝建议迈克尔伴随着《Staying Alive》的旋律进行胸外按压而告终。这很快演变成了一场彻头彻尾的舞会。是的，整场戏太棒了。太搞笑了。我觉得是时候和罗宾聊聊这件事了。所以以下是我们对饰演罗丝——CPR教练的罗宾·林奇的采访。嘿，伙计们。办公室女郎。我们太高兴你能来了。哦，你看起来一点都没变。
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
So do you guys.
I feel like nothing.
Time has not changed, my friends.
Everything is good.
We're so excited that you're joining us today.
We have been, you know, we rewatched every episode of the show, but we've been revisiting
哦，天哪。谢谢。你们也是。我觉得什么都没变。时间没有改变我的朋友们。一切都很好。我们很高兴你能加入我们。我们一直在，你知道的，我们重看了剧中的每一集，但我们每个星期一都在重新温习
them every Monday.
And oh my gosh, we found all this extra footage from your CPR scenes and the superfan.
Have you seen it?
I honestly just watched it the other night.
So all this time has gone by, and I have only seen what everyone else saw on that original
airing. So I sat there. I'm watching it. I'm like, oh, yeah, I totally forgot. I forgot about all those
extra lines and that interaction with the cast with Steve Corrello. It was brilliant. I sat there.
I was like, and all I thought was my skin looks great.
它们。哦，天哪，我们在超级粉丝版中发现了所有来自你CPR场景的额外素材。你看过了吗？老实说，我前几天刚看。所以这么长时间过去了，我只看过大家在最初播出时看到的内容。所以我坐在那儿看。我一边看一边想，“哦，对，我全忘了。”我把那些额外的台词以及与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）的互动都忘了。太精彩了。我坐在那儿想，我当时唯一的想法是：我的皮肤看起来真好。
That was my takeaway. You look fantastic.
Well, you know what? We were thrilled to watch the scenes, too, and we were cracking up.
thank you for being here today.
We're going to kick this off with this question.
How did you get your role as Rose, the CPR instructor on the office?
Because you know, I wondered if you were a real CPR.
You were convinced.
Yes.
这就是我的收获。你看起来棒极了。好吧，你知道吗？我们看这些场景时也激动不已，我们笑得前仰后合。谢谢你今天来到这里。我们要用这个问题来开启访谈：你是如何获得《办公室》中罗丝——CPR教练这个角色的？因为你知道，我一直想知道你是不是一个真正的CPR人员。你当时确信。是的。
Yeah.
Thank you.
That is, on a side note, when you talked about that in the podcast about stress relief,
I think it was like two years ago.
Yeah, yeah.
I was getting my carpet steamed.
Oh.
And my CPA called me.
是的。谢谢。顺便提一下，当你在播客中谈到《减压》时，那大概是两年前吧。对，对。我当时正在蒸地毯。哦。我的注册会计师给我打电话。
And he's like, Robin, the girls are talking about you about your office episode.
They thought you were a real nurse.
And I'm like, I thought it was a real.
Like, I had no idea that was happening.
So, of course, I immediately listened and cried because I was like, oh, my gosh, that's like the biggest compliment.
An actor can ever hear that they actually, someone actually thinks that that's what they're, who they really are.
Yes.
So thank you.
他说，罗宾，这几个女孩在播客里谈论你的办公室那一集。她们以为你是个真正的护士。我说，我还以为是个真的……就像我完全不知道这回事。所以，当然，我立刻听了，然后哭了，因为我想，哦，天哪，这简直是一个演员能听到的最高赞美——居然真的有人认为那就是她的真实身份。是的。所以谢谢你们。
Thank you.
Cried like a baby.
You definitely nailed the realism.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it didn't matter how crazy the room got.
it was like, I'm just here to do this job and I'm trying my best to do it.
And that's not easy to do when you have a bunch of wackadoos all around you.
谢谢你们。哭得像个婴儿。你确实把逼真度拿捏得死死的。是的。是的。不管房间里有多疯狂，这都不重要。就像是我只是来这里做这份工作的，我在尽最大努力完成它。当你身边有一群疯子时，要做到这一点可不容易。
Well, that was the bottom line is when I got the script.
And I knew the show.
So that was important.
So what happened was my agent reached out to me, who by the way, I never actually met this agent in person.
It was one of those online agents like you get them online through actors access or whatever.
So he had never seen me in person.
And when he sent me on the audition, the description was a 60, 60, 6.0.
year old, six zero, six zero year old and draconous woman.
好吧，最底线的是当我拿到剧本时。而且我了解这部剧。所以这很重要。事情是这样的，我的经纪人联系了我，顺便说一下，我其实从未在现实中见过这个经纪人。这是一个在线经纪人，就像你通过Actors Access或其他途径在线认识的那种。所以他从未在现实中见过我。当他给我发试镜通知时，角色描述是一个60，60，6.0岁，六零，六零岁且严厉的女性。
So I get, I get the breakdown.
I'm like, I know this guy hasn't seen me before, but okay, whatever.
So I, you know, I go to the audition and it's Allison Jones casting.
And is it okay if I ask you how old you were as opposed to not being 60?
Oh, 35.
Okay.
No, 35.
So I'm like, okay, cool.
所以我拿到了角色简介。我想，我知道这家伙以前没见过我，但好吧，随它去吧。所以，你知道的，我去试镜了，那是艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones）选角工作室。请问我可以问一下你当时多大吗，毕竟你并没有60岁？哦，35岁。好吧。不，35岁。所以我当时想，好吧，太棒了。
So I go, I'm waiting with these lovely women that were of that age.
Okay.
And I'm just sitting there like, I don't know what's going to happen.
I'm just happy to be here.
Happy to be here.
But I remember the direction that Ben Harris gave me, which was, he's like, just don't act.
Just don't.
It's okay.
所以我就去了，和那些达到那个年龄段的可爱女性们一起等待。好吧。我只是坐在那里心想，不知道会发生什么。我只是很高兴能来。很高兴能来。但我记得本·哈里斯（Ben Harris）给我的指导，那就是，他说，别演。千万别演。没关系。
And that's what we did.
And that was like, and you knew the show.
So you knew sort of the tone of it.
I knew the show and I knew that y'all didn't want me to sing it.
It was more me going to use it to teach CPR.
So that's what I did.
And I just kept it simple.
And we, and I didn't have.
我们就是这么做的。而且就像是，你了解这部剧。所以你大概知道它的基调。我了解这部剧，我知道你们不需要我一本正经地演。它更多是让我用它来教CPR。所以我就是这么做的。我保持了简单。而且我们，我没有
a lot of time really to overanalyze things because I was on set the very next day.
Wow.
You were in the audition room the day prior?
Yes.
So I 15 pages of dialogue.
And I was like, all right.
15 pages for the audition?
Oh my goodness.
真正的时间去过度分析事情，因为我第二天就进组了。哇。你前一天还在试镜室？是的。我有15页的台词。我就想，好吧。试镜要15页？哦，天哪。
And you had to be off books.
So I'm like, okay, let's go.
And we just had so much fun.
And it was, I left and it was so nice.
Ben was like, nice working with you.
And I was like, I'm like, yay.
And so for me, I had.
already won. I was like, I went in there, did my thing, Ben was cool. I'm like, awesome. And then
而且你必须完全脱稿。所以我心想，好吧，我们上吧。我们玩得太开心了。我离开时感觉真好。本说，合作愉快。我就想，耶。所以对我来说，我已经赢了。我心想，我去了，做了我该做的事，本觉得很酷，太棒了。然后
an hour later they called and said, we need you on set tomorrow at 12th. And I was like,
an hour later. An hour later on my flip bone. Those were the days. Those are the days when you're
driving with your flip on. I was like, okay, so I just got home, ran over the lines. And the next morning,
I worked out. And I just didn't have time to freak out. And I just got to set when I got there,
Angela, I think I was wearing a pair of your pants.
They couldn't find anything for me to wear.
I was wearing my purple jacket.
I wore that.
一个小时后他们打电话说，我们明天12点需要你到片场。我就想，一个小时后？一个小时后，在我的翻盖手机上。那真是个好时光。那是开着翻盖手机开车的年代。我想，好吧，我刚到家，把台词过了一遍。第二天早上，我锻炼了一下。我根本没时间抓狂。我一到片场，安吉拉，我想我当时穿着一条你的裤子。他们找不到任何适合我穿的衣服。我穿着我的紫色夹克。我穿了那个。
That's mine.
But they just kept layering me.
Because when I watched the episode the other day, I was like, God, it looked like a
habit.
I looked so small.
So they kept like putting all these layers on me, I think, to make me look like a human,
which is great.
And off we went.
那是我的。但他们只是不断给我叠穿。因为我前几天看那一集的时候，心想，天哪，我看起来就像个修女。我看起来太小了。所以我猜他们一直给我穿各种厚重的衣服，为了让我看起来像个人类，这挺棒的。然后我们就上场了。
And I remember we did one rehearsal.
And again, Jeffrey Blitz was great.
He just came over and said, don't act.
Just do it.
And we just did it.
You just did it.
And they were throwing you curveballs left and right.
They were so funny.
我记得我们排练了一次。而且，杰弗里·布里茨（Jeffrey Blitz）真的很好。他走过来对我说，别演。只管做就行。我们就照做了。你们就照做了。他们左右开弓给你出难题。他们太搞笑了。
Ed Helms, that little rascal, he was trying to make me laugh the whole time.
He almost got me.
He almost did.
When we rewatch the super fan, he does this thing where he hip checks you.
Like he turns while he's dancing and kind of like hits you with his tush.
And you kind of bump.
And you're like, what is happening?
That's exactly.
埃德·希尔斯（Ed Helms），那个小淘气，他一直在逗我笑。他差点把我逗笑。他差点就成功了。当我们重看超级粉丝版时，他做了这样一个动作：他用臀部撞了你一下。就像他跳舞时转过身，用臀部撞了你一下。你踉跄了一下。你当时想，这到底在发生什么？完全就是这样。
My face, I was just like, don't laugh.
go do it. And then, you know, I remember Mindy is up there, Dan, I was just like, and remember,
I didn't know anything about the episode. I didn't get your script. I only got my part. So when I showed
up, oh, that's interesting. I had no idea what was going on. I heard you guys talking about a cat
falling. And I remember being very like, do they throw animals? What was going on? I'm like,
I'm like, whatever. And I was in my lane. I'm like, okay, just, okay, where am I stand here? And then,
And as I watched it the other day, I'm like, oh, I see why they did how they actually had Steve, like, leaning over and everyone was sitting in chairs.
I'm so short that they had to kind of work with the height and have the cast.
我的表情就像是，别笑，继续演。然后，你知道的，我记得明迪（Mindy）也在上面，丹，我当时就想——记住，我对这一集一无所知。我没有拿到你们的剧本。我只拿到了我的部分。所以当我出现时——哦，那挺有意思的。我完全不知道发生了什么。我听到你们在讨论一只猫掉下来。我记得当时非常疑惑：他们会扔动物吗？到底怎么回事？我心想，不管了。我只管走好我自己的流程。心想，好吧，我就站在这儿？然后，前几天我重看的时候心想，哦，我明白了为什么他们会这样安排——他们实际上让史蒂夫弓着身子，其他人坐在椅子上。我个子太矮了，所以他们必须配合身高，让演员们……
And it was like, oh, that's brilliant.
That really worked great.
Was that, like, dancing part of it?
Was that the hardest to keep a straight face?
Oh, I would say the entire thing.
I mean, literally, yeah.
That was the hardest part.
But when Creed says his line, that was a moment Steve and I had with him.
感觉就像，哦，这太妙了。效果真的很好。那个跳舞的桥段是其中之一吗？那是保持不笑最难的部分吗？哦，我会说是整场戏。我的意思是，字面意义上的，对。那是超级难的部分。但当克里德（Creed）说出他的台词时，那是我和史蒂夫经历的一个时刻。
We're like, what, what are you saying?
What's happening?
And I'm just like, you can see, if you really look, you can see me.
Whenever I puckered, I'm like, don't do it.
Also, Steve is Michael in the extended scenes.
He really goes at Rose.
He's like, you know what, Rose?
Do your job.
我们俩当时想，什、什么？你在说什么？发生什么了？我当时就想——你能看出来，如果你仔细看的话，你能看到我。每当我抿起嘴唇，我就在想：别笑，千万别笑。还有，史蒂夫在加长版里饰演的迈克尔。他真的死缠着罗丝不放。他说，你知道吗，罗丝？做你的工作。
Like, he gets very antagonistic with you.
Yeah.
I know.
I've forgotten all of that.
So when I was watching it, I'm like, oh, that's so funny.
But Rose, I mean, it's my character.
She just kind of kept telling that line.
Kept it moving, kept it going.
就像，他对你变得非常具有对抗性。是的。我知道。我都忘光了。所以当我看着它时，心想，哦，这太搞笑了。但罗丝，我的意思是，这就是我的角色。她只是顺着那句台词演下去了。继续推进，继续演。
I wonder like, what stories did Rose tell her friend and significant other when she left
that office that day, right?
Like, you guys are not going to believe what happened to the day.
I'm pretty sure Rose changed careers.
In my mind, Rose, like, forget this.
I'm going to go to HR.
I'm going to be, I'm going to go work with trees.
I'm done.
我在想，罗丝那天离开办公室后，会对她的朋友和另一半说些什么故事呢？对吧？就像，你们绝对不会相信今天发生了什么。我敢肯定罗丝换了职业。在我心里，罗丝当时的想法是：算了吧，老娘不干了。我要去找人力资源。我要去，我要去和树木打交道。我受够了。
Like, you can tell she was at the end of her rope.
Yeah, we broke Rose, unfortunately.
Basically, I think you did.
When Dwight stabbed the CPR tummy, that was pretty much it for Rose.
We are so curious if you have like a favorite memory from being on set or any kind of behind the scenes thing that you hold dear.
Well, I would say for you, Miss Angela, you were just so kind.
I remember that you made sure I had clothes.
You told me where to put the clothes at the end.
就像，你能看出她当时已经忍无可忍了。对，我们把罗丝逼疯了，不幸的是。基本上，我觉得你们确实做到了。当德怀特用刀刺向CPR假人时，罗丝的心理防线基本上就彻底崩塌了。我们很好奇，你是否有来自片场的最喜欢的记忆，或者任何你珍视的幕后故事？好吧，我要说的是，安吉拉女士，你真的太善良了。我记得你确保我有衣服穿。你告诉我结束时把衣服放在哪里。
It was like 11 at night.
I'm like, where do I put my war?
everyone was gone.
I'm like, where do I put my wardrobe?
And you're like, just leave it in your trailer.
And I remember leaving and just being like, that is so nice.
I felt like I could go out with you guys afterwards.
It was just a warm set.
当时大概晚上11点了。我心想，我的衣服该放哪儿？所有人都走了。我心想，我的戏服该放哪儿？你说，直接留在你的拖车里就行。我记得我离开时心里想：这人太好了。我觉得我甚至可以和你们一起出去玩了。那是一个温暖的片场。
Everyone was lovely.
And I felt like a receiving line at the end of everyone was like shaking my hand.
And I was, you know, I'm just like, I honestly, when I went to set, kind of was like,
oh, you know, they're going to probably cut some of these lines.
It's a lot of lines.
And I, you know, and I was convinced, I still am convinced that I mean,
may have replaced them the last minute.
We are not aware of that.
每个人都超级可爱。我觉得自己就像是在接受夹道欢送，最后每个人都在跟我握手。而我，你知道的，我当时心里想——说实话，当我进片场时，我还以为，哦，你知道的，他们可能会剪掉其中一些台词。台词太多了。而且，你知道的，我当时深信不疑，现在依然深信不疑，那就是梅伊（May）可能在最后一分钟替换了它们。我们并不知道这回事。
That is a story I tell myself all the time because it was such a quick cast.
We move pretty fast sometimes, though.
So I would say toot your own horn, lady.
I think that part was yours all along.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I definitely felt like when I was on set, even watching it the other day, I was like,
oh, yeah, I was supposed to be there.
那是我经常对自己讲的一个故事，因为节奏太快了。有时候我们的进展确实相当快。所以我要说，女郎，好样的，给自己点个赞。我觉得那部分从头到尾就是你的。是的。哦，是的。我绝对觉得当我在片场时，甚至前几天看的时候，我都在想：哦，对，我本来就应该在那儿。
That's a night.
It was such a nice feeling.
So having those wonderful feelings are kind of what I take away from the office.
And it was surreal for me to be looking.
Like when Steve Carrell was like, hi, I'm Steve Carrell.
I'm like, in my head.
There's like a squirrel in my head being like,
Steve Carrella is walking up to you.
那种感觉真好。所以拥有那些美妙的感觉是我从《办公室》带走的收获。而且看着这一切对我来说太超现实了。就像当史蒂夫·卡瑞尔走过来时说：“嗨，我是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。”我心里想。我脑子里有只松鼠在尖叫：史蒂夫·卡瑞尔正朝你走过来。
Steve Corrella was putting out his ear.
Steve Carrella said hello to you.
Steve Carell is really in shape.
I'm like, wow, he's really in shape.
I mean, this is what was going on in my head.
And then I'm just like, keep it together.
Rain Wilson kept trying to give me high fives.
I could not reach.
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔向你伸出了手。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔跟你打招呼了。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔身材真好。我心想，哇，他身材真好。我的意思是，这就是我脑子里正在发生的事情。然后我只能对自己说：稳住，撑住。雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）一直试图跟我击掌。但我够不着。
He kept doing that.
I was like, dude, I can't reach.
And then someone did ask.
I think it was, I think it was Rain or Ed said, hey, are you a nurse? I'm like, no.
Well, where does this role rank in terms of film and television appearances for you?
Because you're saying this was a new agent. This was someone who you hadn't even met in person.
And now you go out and you book this role.
Huge. It was completely huge. You know, one of the things I did when I moved to L.A.
他一直在这么做。我心想，老兄，我够不着。然后有人问了。我想是雷恩或者埃德问的，嘿，你是护士吗？我说，不。好吧，这个角色在你所有的影视作品出场中排在什么位置？因为你刚才说这是一个新经纪人。这是一个你甚至在现实中都没见过的人。而现在你出去接下了这个角色。太重要了。这绝对太重要了。你知道，我刚搬到洛杉矶时做的一件事是，
after college as I went and worked in a casting office for a few months, just an internship.
And it was one of the best things I ever did as an actor because I really could watch how a part meets a person.
It's a serendipity.
It's this magic thing.
It's their part.
And years later, when I'm auditioning and I'm, you know, I'm in the hustle.
I'm just trying to meet people, you know, get as much experience as possible.
When it happened to me, like emotionally spiritual, everything, I was like, oh, it is true.
大学毕业后我去一家选角办公室工作了几个月，只是实习。那是作为演员我做过的最好的事情之一，因为我真的能观察到一个角色是如何与一个人相遇的。这是一种机缘巧合。这是一件神奇的事情。这是属于他们的角色。多年后，当我一直在试镜，你知道的，我在为生计奔波。我只是想见更多人，你知道的，获得尽可能多的经验。当它真的发生在我身上时——无论是情感上、精神上还是方方面面——我心想，哦，这是真的。
It does happen, you know, to have that actually happen.
And as far as credits, huge, huge credits.
the biggest push, obviously when the Super Bowl aired and we watched it, it was the first hour-long
episode and won an Emmy.
Yeah.
So this is a no-joke episode.
So thrilled, so thankful to be part of that.
But when Netflix put it on the network during the pandemic area, like era, that then gave me a new audience.
它真的会发生，你知道的，当这一切真正发生时。就演艺履历而言，超级重磅的履历。最大的推动力显然是超级碗播出的时候，我们观看了它，那是第一集长达一小时的剧集，还赢得了艾美奖。是的。所以这是一集毫不含糊的重磅剧集。非常激动，非常感谢能成为其中一员。但当Netflix在大流行期间将它上线时，那为我带来了一批全新的观众。
And not only did I have the parents that watched the office at their kids.
So that's another reason why, you know, I waited tables forever.
So I would wait on people and people say, hey, aren't you Rosa CPRN's director?
I'm like, yeah, I am.
How are you?
And in fact, I was getting a facial yesterday and my facialist said, aren't you roses?
I mean, it's crazy.
So that is the strongest movement.
不仅有看《办公室》的父母，还有他们的孩子。所以这也是为什么，你知道的，我当了那么久的餐厅服务员。我会在餐厅招待客人，人们会说：“嘿，你不是那个CPR护士罗丝吗？”我说：“对，我是。你好吗？”事实上，我昨天在做面部护理时，我的美容师说：“你不是罗丝吗？”我的意思是，这太疯狂了。所以那是持续时间最长的影响力。
When you look at other pieces of work, like projects that I have developed or been in that
have other special meetings, but this one is really special.
And I knew it when I was on set.
I'm like, this is something special is going to happen here.
So.
Was it wild to see that?
after the Super Bowl.
Like as you're sitting there,
当你回顾其他的作品时，比如我开发过或参演过的、有其他特殊意义的项目，但这一部真的很特别。当我还在片场时我就知道了。我想：这里将要发生一些非常特别的事情。所以。当时看到那个情景，是不是觉得太疯狂了？在超级碗之后。就像你坐在那里，
like if you go back in time,
like take me back to like you're sitting on your couch
and you know you have the Super Bowl audience.
Well, we learned something that night.
First of all, if you're in a big episode of a show,
don't invite everybody over.
What?
I invited like a ton of people.
如果时光倒流——带我回到你坐在沙发上的时候，你知道你有超级碗的观众群体。好吧，那天晚上我们学到了一个教训。首先，如果你在一部大热剧集的大制作剧集里，千万不要邀请所有人到家里来。什么？我邀请了一大堆人。
I had like a party at my house.
At that time, I was married.
So my husband was there and his friends.
It was like a gorgeous little party.
And I was so nervous.
I was like, I don't know how this is going to go.
I mean, this could be awful.
Because you haven't seen it yet, right?
我在家里办了个派对。那时候我结婚了。所以我的丈夫和他的朋友们都在那儿。那是个非常棒的小派对。我当时紧张极了。我想，我不知道这会怎么样。我的意思是，这可能会糟透了。因为你当时还没看过，对吧？
You haven't pre-screened it.
You don't know.
I had no idea.
And I was like, I will never do that again.
I will just let you know when it's airing and good luck with that because it was too stressful.
So when I watched it, I was, it was nervous the whole time.
And then I was like, oh, yeah, I did that.
Okay, good.
你还没有提前审片。你什么都不知道。我完全不知道。我心想，我再也不会这么做了。我以后只会告诉你们它什么时候播出的，祝你们好运，因为这实在太令人焦虑了。所以当我观看时，我全程都很紧张。然后我心想，哦，对，我演了那个。好吧，很好。
Again, I knew something special.
When the Emmys were happening, I was, this time I was by myself.
And, you know, I'm just like, I'm not going to risk that again.
And I was like, and I didn't even know the episode was up.
for an Emmy. I was just like, I'm going to watch the Emmys. See what happens. And I was like,
that's the episode. It's so fantastic. So it was, again, for me, I always tell folks,
it's the gift that keeps given. It just keeps given. Yeah. Like, even today, it's so lovely to see
you guys. It's so wonderful to talk about work that means a lot, not just to me, but when I,
再次说明，我知道这很特别。当艾美奖颁奖典礼举行时，这一次我独自一人。而且，你知道的，我心想，我不会再冒那个险了。我想——我当时甚至不知道这一集入围了艾美奖。我只是想，我要看艾美奖。看看会发生什么。然后我就看到，这就是那一集。太棒了。所以这对我来说，我总是告诉大家，这是源源不断给予的礼物。它一直在给予。是的。甚至在今天，见到你们也是如此美好。谈论那些不仅对我意义重大、而且当我
I get recognized, people are thrilled. They're not, they're just, it makes them so happy,
brings so much joy. Like, to be a part of that, I'm, I feel. I feel.
like the luckiest girl in the world.
Well, you're a huge part of that.
I mean, there's many episodes, obviously, that are fan favorites,
but this is one of the big tent pole episodes.
And I love that people just come up and share their joy with you,
because that's how we feel, too.
被认出来时人们都欣喜若狂的工作，这种感觉太美妙了。他们不是别的，这只是让他们感到如此快乐，带来了这么多的喜悦。能够成为其中的一部分，我感到——我感到。我是世界上最幸运的女孩。好吧，你绝对是其中不可或缺的一部分。我的意思是，显然有很多集都是粉丝的最爱，但这一集是绝对的核心顶梁柱剧集之一。我很高兴人们会走过来与你分享他们的喜悦，因为这也是我们的感受。
Everyone's so nice.
Yeah.
And your fan base is lovely.
And what you're doing with the show is so lovely.
And I hope you guys know that.
It's like, I don't know if people tell you enough that what you're building is this wonderful,
warm community of positivity when you talk to your fans and answer their questions.
And listening, I listen to your podcast and I feel like I'm talking like you're in my car
每个人都超级好。是的。你们的粉丝群体太可爱了。而且你们通过这个节目所做的事情也非常可爱。我希望你们知道这一点。就像，我不知道是否有人足够经常地告诉你们，你们正在建立的是一个充满积极性的奇妙、温暖的社区，当你们与粉丝交流并回答他们的问题时。而且我在听，我听你们的播客，我觉得我就像是在和你对话，就像你在我的车里
with me.
Like they're not in there, even how you talk about your products like the advertisement,
the way that you describe.
I'm just like, oh my gosh, totally gets that.
Okay, I get it.
It's such a breakthrough with your stuff.
We did win an award for our ad reads.
Oh, yeah, you did.
陪着我一样。就像他们不在那儿一样，甚至连你们谈论产品的方式，比如广告，你们描述的方式。我当时就想，哦，天哪，完全懂那种感觉。好吧，我明白了。你们的东西太有突破性了。我们的广告词确实得过奖。哦，对，你们得过。
We were super excited.
We were proud of that.
You know, that's.
It's like, this show is free and it's paid for by advertising, but we're like, they don't need to be boring to listen to.
So thank you for that compliment.
Yeah.
You're so welcome.
Well, Robin, what are you working on right now?
我们当时超级兴奋。我们为之骄傲。你知道，那就像，这个节目是免费的，它是由广告资助的，但我们认为，听广告并不需要变得枯燥乏味。所以谢谢你的赞美。是的。不客气。好吧，罗宾，你现在在忙些什么？
Is there anything we can shout out to our listeners?
Sure.
Thank you for asking.
So this has been a really fun year.
I've been pivoting from an actor, but also writer-performer.
So I just completed my first pilot for a comedy.
It's actually a drama.
It's a drominy disguised as a comedy.
有什么我们可以向我们的听众宣传的吗？当然。谢谢你的提问。所以这真的是充满乐趣的一年。我一直在从演员转型，同时也兼任编剧兼表演者。所以我刚刚完成了我的第一部喜剧试播集。其实是一部正剧。这是一部伪装成喜剧的正剧。
Okay.
I like this thing. Last year was an interesting year for me. I had multiple jobs. You know,
after COVID and the strikes, you know, we had the union strikes. It was, it's been a bit crazy
out here in L.A. So I ended up having a few jobs. And one of the jobs that I had, I worked at a medical
device company here in Los Angeles. And it's a call center. And I remember walking and saying,
oh my God, this is a show. So I wrote my first pilot about that in Pitch Check and Treatment. So now I'm
sharing it and getting feedback.
And it's called On the Line.
好的。我喜欢这个设定。去年对我来说是有趣的一年。我有多重工作。你知道，在疫情和罢工之后，你知道的，我们经历了工会罢工。在洛杉矶这里一直有点疯狂。所以我最后做了一些工作。其中一份工作是，我在洛杉矶的一家医疗器械公司工作。那是一个呼叫中心。我记得走进去时心想，哦，天哪，这就是个电视剧。所以我以那段经历写了我的第一部试播集，并做了推介和提案。现在我正在分享它并收集反馈。它叫《在线》（On the Line）。
And the fun part about this show and the experience that I had was this office is like
still in 1982.
And they're dealing with people with medical devices that work.
The device is great.
But how they run the joint is like from the 80s.
And I remember just sitting there going and the characters that it was the ensemble cast.
It was brilliant.
I'm like, this is so rich.
这部剧有趣的地方以及我的亲身经历是，这个办公室感觉还停留在1982年。他们要处理带有医疗器械的人。设备本身很棒。但他们运营这个地方的方式就像是80年代的产物。我记得当时坐在那里心想——而且其中的群像角色真的太精彩了。我心想，这太丰富了。
I stayed there for three months and did like recon.
I just like pulled, pulled, pulled, and then I sat and I wrote.
And I'm like, being an actor has been wonderful, but be able to transition to writing as well.
I feel very thankful.
It's like opening up a whole new world for me.
So that's what I'm working on right now.
It's very exciting.
That's wonderful.
我在那里呆了三个月，进行了类似于侦察的工作。我一直在挖掘、挖掘、挖掘，然后我坐下来开始写作。我心想，当演员固然很棒，但能转型进行写作，我感到非常感恩。这就像为我打开了一个全新世界。所以这就是我目前在忙的项目。非常令人兴奋。太棒了。
Yeah, you'll have to update us as things go because that's so exciting.
I'll let you know.
Aw, this was so great.
Thank you for spending this time with us and going over these scenes.
And like Angela said, this episode is just really.
beloved, but these scenes are really beloved. And it's one of the most memorable parts of the whole
series as this CPR training day. Rain says he gets that, he gets a lot of memes of himself.
We all do, right? Like they show up. But the one where he's cut the face off the dummy.
是的，事情有进展时你得随时更新我们，因为这太令人兴奋了。我会告诉你们的。天哪，太棒了。谢谢你花时间陪我们聊这些场景。就像安吉拉说的，这一集真的备受喜爱，但这些场景更是备受喜爱。作为整个剧集中最难忘的部分之一，这个CPR培训日。雷恩说他经历过这个，他收到了很多关于他自己的表情包。我们都有，对吧？就像它们到处都是。但其中一个是他把假人的脸切下来的那个。
Yep. And everyone is screaming at him. And also all the real lives that have been saved
from people who remember the stay-in-alive advice.
Yes.
Do people share that with you?
So what happens, you know, I am a little, you know, a funny person.
I'm always making little jokes, but I was like, you know, we're actors.
没错。每个人都在对他尖叫。还有那些因为记住了“保持活著”的急救建议而获救的真实生命。是的。大家会跟你分享这些吗？会的。会的。所以你知道的，我有点，你知道，是个有趣的人。我总是开点小玩笑，但我当时想，你知道的，我们是演员。
We're not like saving lives.
But then I started getting articles from people around the country saying they used it to save like someone in Arizona used it.
A woman saved a squirrel with it.
And I'm like, we are saving lives.
I mean, that's actually happening with that song.
And I thought that was very, very sweet.
But people do share that with me often.
It's crazy that this,
我们并不是在拯救生命。但后来我开始收到来自全国各地人们的来信，说他们用这个救了人，比如亚利桑那州有人用它救了人。有个女人用它救了一只松鼠。我就想，我们在拯救生命。我的意思是，那首歌确实起到了这样的作用。我觉得这非常非常温馨。不过大家确实经常跟我分享这些。真疯狂，这个，
culturally, everyone knows about this scene and about this song.
So it's pretty cool.
Really cool.
In rewatching it, I forgot how much Michael, like, came alive when,
I think it was the first thing Rose said that made any sense or was any fun to him
when Rose is like, actually, do you know staying alive by the Bee Gees?
He's like, I do.
从文化层面上讲，每个人都知道这个场景和这首歌。所以这真的很酷。真的很酷。真的很酷。在重看的时候，我忘了迈克尔表现得多么有活力，当，我想那是罗斯说的第一句有意义或者让他觉得有趣的话，当时罗斯说，其实，你知道比吉斯乐队的《Staying Alive》吗？他说，我知道。
He was so, he was like, Rose and I are about to jam.
So great.
And then he got the song wrong.
It was so great.
You started at the wrong spot and you're like, no, it's this part.
The course.
Yeah.
No, it was actually the wrong song.
他当时超，他就像是，罗斯和我准备要嗨起来了。太棒了。然后他把歌词唱错了。太棒了。你从错误的地方开始唱，然后你就像，不对，是这一段。副歌。对。不对，那其实是另一首歌。
That was, I will.
He was singing, I will survive.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Yes, yes, you're right.
Which is actually so perfect.
Well, is there anything from your time on the show or anything that you wanted to share that
那是，我会的。他唱的是《I Will Survive》。哦，对，没错。没错。没错。是的，是的，你说的对。这其实太完美了。好吧，关于你在剧组的时光，或者有什么你想分享的吗
we missed. Just again, so surreal, so quick. When I got there, they were just trying to put clothes on me.
I don't even think they put makeup on me. They were like, let's get her dressed. And off to the set,
we went. And I had, it was, you know, shot in Van Eyes. I had never been to Van Nuys before.
I was living on the west side. So I remember being like, wow, this is the valley.
Now I live out here. So I'm like, oh, yeah, it's right down the street. But I just remember in the
parking lot when I got there in my little corolla, I pull up my corolla. And Creed actually said,
I know you. He actually gave me the line in the parking lot before we even started. And I do see him,
by the way, at our Ralphs. Like I live right here where the Ralphs is. And like, I've seen him at Petco.
我们漏掉了。只是再次觉得，太不真实了，太快了。当我到那儿时，他们只是在给我套衣服。我甚至觉得他们都没给我化妆。他们就说，让她穿上衣服。然后我们就去了片场。而且我，你知道的，是在范奈斯拍的。我以前从没去过范奈斯。我住在西区。所以我记得当时想，哇，这就是山谷啊。现在我就住在附近。所以我就会想，哦，对，就在街头。但我只记得当我开着我的小花冠车到达停车场时，我把车停好。克里德竟然说，我认识你。甚至在我们开始之前，他就在停车场跟我对过台词了。顺便说一句，我在我们的拉尔夫超市见过他。就像我就住在拉尔夫超市这附近。而且，我在审宠物世界见过他。
And he doesn't have a pet. And I'm like, what you doing here? He's like, I don't know. My grandfather,
my granddaughter. His daughter, yeah, has a dog. Yeah. It's so funny. But I just, again, I feel so
blessed that I got to work with you guys and have this experience and bring Rose to life. And yeah,
poor Rose after that, she definitely got a new job.
She quit.
She went on holiday for two weeks and never came back.
I'm out of here.
But yeah, so it was just a wonderful experience.
而且他没有宠物。我就想，你在这干嘛？他说，我不知道。我爷爷，我孙女。他的女儿，对，有一只狗。对。太搞笑了。但我只是，再次觉得，我能和你们一起工作并有这段经历，把罗斯带进现实，我感到非常幸运。是的，在那之后可怜的罗斯，她绝对是换了一份新工作。她辞职了。她去度假两周，就再也没有回来。我才不干呢。不过，是的，所以这是一次非常棒的经历。
And everyone was so kind.
So thank you.
And thank you for having me on today just to connect.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, it took us so long to connect,
but I'm so glad we finally did.
Yeah, thank you for reaching out.
Yeah.
每个人都超级好。所以谢谢你们。也谢谢你们今天邀请我来串门。对。对不起，我们联系花了这么久，但我很高兴我们最终联系上了。对，谢谢你主动联系。对。
Of course.
My pleasure.
And I'll keep you guys posted when on the line gets a little traction.
Yeah.
We'd love it.
Oh, cool.
All right.
Take care, Robin.
当然。我的荣幸。如果有后续进展，我会随时向大家汇报的。好的。我们会很期待的。哦，酷。好啦，保重，罗宾。
Thanks, Robin.
Bye.
Well, that was just lovely.
Once again, it just brings me so much happiness to get to reconnect with people who are on the show.
And I love hearing how even just this one-day role has impacted her life 20 years later.
It's really cool.
谢谢你，罗宾。拜拜。拜拜。哇，真是太美妙了。再次强调，能够跟剧组的人重新取得联系，总是能带给我极大的快乐。我很高兴听到仅仅是这样一个仅有一天的角色，在20年後依然对她的人生产生了影响。这真的很酷。真的很酷。
And you guys, if you want to find Robin on Cameo, we'll be sharing that link in our stories.
So go and check it out.
All right.
Well, why don't we take a break?
And then we'll be back with Around the Town and our office question of the week.
I'm going to kick us off with an Around the Town.
from our snail mail. This is from Sam K from the United Kingdom. Sam said,
Dear Office ladies, I just wanted to say a genuine thank you for the office in your podcast.
还有大家，如果你想在Cameo上找到罗宾，我们会在动态中分享那个链接。所以快去看看吧。好了，我们为什么不休息一下？然後我们会带着“走遍小镇”环节和本周办公室问答回来。我先用一封平信开启我们的“走遍小镇”环节。这是来自英国的萨姆·K。萨姆说，亲爱的办公室女士们，我只想对《办公室》和你们的播客表达由衷的感谢。
Both the show and the podcast have been a constant companion for me while I'm working.
I spend a lot of time making miniatures at home and prop making. And having something comforting,
funny, and familiar on as I make makes such a difference. What I especially love is when you talk about
props and behind the scenes details. Prop making can often feel like a bit of an inside,
invisible craft in filmmaking. Hearing you highlight that side of things feels really special and
appreciated. Thank you again. Lots of love, Sam Kay. P.S., I hope the gifts arrived okay.
What are the gifts? Lady, he makes miniatures. Stop it. I know. You know, miniatures are my favorite
thing. I know. Is this a miniature? Is that what this box is? That top box, you have to open it. I'm going to
无论是这部剧还是播客，在我工作的时候都一直陪伴着我。我花了很多时间在家制作微缩模型和道具。在我制作的过程中，有这样一档温馨、有趣且熟悉的节目陪伴，真的带来了巨大的改变。我尤其喜欢的是你们谈论道具和幕后细节的时候。在电影制作中，道具制作往往让人觉得有点像一种内行专属的、隐形的工艺。听到你们着重介绍那一方面，真的让人感觉非常特别和感激。再次谢谢你们。满满的爱，萨姆·K。附言，希望礼物顺利送达。什么礼物？女士，他制作了微缩模型。别这样。我知道。你知道的，微缩模型是我的最爱。我知道。这是一个微缩模型吗？这个盒子就是这个吗？那个顶部的盒子，你得打开它。我要去
chairman stories. Isn't it amazing? Oh my God. This is, I could actually cry. It's so beautiful.
We have to describe to everyone. Okay, I have a shadow box with miniatures inside of it, and it is,
it's very Pam-centered, but also office-centered. So I have a little ream of Dundermifflin paper.
There's a little mixed berries yogurt. There is a teapot, a tiny,
teapot with also all the little things that were in the teapot. There is a yogurt lid. I don't even
understand how he made these itty-bitty paper clips. There's an itty-bitty the adventures of Jimmy
Helpert and some little shoes and Pam's watercolor. I mean, I... It's really...
Oh my gosh, and my mug, my pink mug! I know. It's really so special, Sam. I have a lot of the
发动态故事。这难道不惊艳吗？哦，天哪。这个，我真的要哭了。太美了。我们得向大家描述一下。好吧，我有一个里面装着微缩模型的展示盒，它是，它非常以帕姆为中心，但也以办公室为中心。所以里面有一小令邓德米夫林纸。有一小盒混合浆果酸奶。有一个茶壶，一个微型茶壶，里面还装着茶壶里所有的那些小物件。有一个酸奶盖。我甚至不明白他是怎么做出这些微型回形针的。里面有一个微型的《吉米·哈珀特历险记》以及一些小鞋子和帕姆的水彩画。我是说，我……这真的很……哦，天哪，还有我的杯子，我的粉色杯子！我知道。这真的很特别，萨姆。我有很多
similar things Jenna had that are office-centric, but I also have the babies playing jazz poster.
Oh my gosh, you have your Birkenstocks that you were bumping.
Yes, I have Angela and Dwight's Berkenstocks. I have, I have sprinkles collar. I have the little
cherub angel that Dwight keeps after they break up. I have the key that Angela gives Dwight
and, and Dwight's bobblehead. I have the little cat ears. I wore it Halloween. But then in the
middle, I have a baseball hat that says, lady with a hummingbird.
on top of it. Sam, I hope you are listening and I hope you know that I will absolutely treasure this.
This is such a gift. Thank you so much. Thank you for the clear amount of just artistry and detail
詹娜拥有的那些以办公室为中心的相似物品，但我也有婴儿在玩爵士乐的海报。哦，天哪，你竟然有你穿的那双勃肯鞋。是的，我有安吉拉和德 Dwight 的勃肯鞋。我有，我有斯普林克尔斯的项圈。我有德 Dwight 分手后留下的那个小凯鲁宾天使。我有安吉拉给德 Dwight 的钥匙，还有，德 Dwight 的摇头娃娃。我有我在万圣节戴过的小猫耳朵。但在中间，我有一顶棒球帽，上面写着“带蜂鸟的女士”。萨姆，我希望你在听，我希望你知道我会绝对珍藏这个。这真的是一份大礼。非常感谢。谢谢你倾注其中的
that went into this. There's also a Pam's candy dish. It looks just like her candy dish, but little.
But tiny. And it is so special. I'm going to share pictures in our story. Sam, thank you for taking
the time to make these. I hope our podcast keeps you company as you continue prop making.
Well, lady, we also got an invitation that I know you are going to love. This is from Kim L.
in Mendocino, California. Kim said, hello ladies. If you are fans of Angela Lansbury and
murder she wrote, you might want to come to my hometown. What? I'm not sure if you know this,
but Mendocino hosts the Murder She Wrote Festival.
Wait for it, lady.
清晰可见的艺术性和细节。里面还有一个帕姆的糖果盘。它看起来跟她的糖果盘一模一样，但是很小。但是非常迷你。这真的太特别了。我会在动态里分享照片的。萨姆，谢谢你花时间制作这些。希望在我们继续制作道具的同时，我们的播客能一直陪伴着你。好吧，女士，我们还收到了一份我知道你一定会喜欢的邀请。这是来自加利福尼亚州门多西诺的金·L。金说，嗨，女士们。如果你是安吉拉·兰斯伯里和《女作家谋杀案》的粉丝，你可能会想来我的家乡。什么？我不确定你们知不知道，门多西诺举办“女作家谋杀案”节。等着瞧吧，女士。
Years ago, they used to film here for the outside shots of the fictional town, Cabot Cove,
and now we host the Murder She Wrote Festival.
People come to celebrate the show, and there are so many fun events like trivia games,
a costume contest, and there's a Jessica jog where people dress up in blonde wigs and gray sweatsuits and run through the streets.
Oh, I should say, not only is it a fun weekend, but proceeds from ticket sales, go to support the Kelly House Museum, which is Mendocino's local history nonprofit.
Kim included a flyer. Kim also said this year it's sold out, so put it on your calendar for next spring and come visit. Maybe you could even do a travel journal about it.
Kim, are you kidding me? Look at this flyer. One of the things, if you buy a pass, it says you can participate.
in a salve-along murder she wrote. It's like lady. That's mom detectives happening.
多年前，他们曾在这里拍摄虚构小镇卡伯特湾的外景，现在我们举办“女作家谋杀案”节。人们聚集来庆祝这部剧，这里有许多有趣的活动，比如冷知识问答、服装比赛，还有一个“杰西卡慢跑”，人们穿着金发假发和灰色运动套装在街上奔跑。哦，我应该说，这不仅是一个有趣的周末，门票销售的收益还将用于支持凯利浩斯博物馆，这是门多西诺当地的历史非营利组织。金随信附上了一张传单。金还说今年票已经卖光了，所以请把它记在明春的日程上并来参观。也许你们甚至可以为此做一篇旅行日记。金，你在开玩笑吗？看看这张传单。其中一项活动，如果你买了一张通票，上面说你可以参与
And we could do a travel journal. We could do a whole episode about it.
I want to go. So this year it happened in early May. So let's keep our eye out.
Okay. Kim, thanks for the tip. And finally from Jared B. in Alliance, Ohio. So this one really
cracked me up, okay? Okay. Because I am getting Google alerts, you guys. Not for myself.
I'll continue to share.
Jarrett, I had heard of this, but it tickled me that you wrote in.
So Jarrett says, there is a woman running for Stark County Auditor named Angela Kinsey.
You guys, it's spelled exactly the same way.
一场伴随《女作家谋杀案》的药膏制作活动。这就像，女士。那是妈妈侦探在现实中上演。我们可以做一篇旅行日记。我们可以为此做一整集节目。我想去。所以今年它发生在五月初。所以让我们留意一下。好吧。金，谢谢你的小贴士。最後是来自俄亥俄州阿联酋的贾雷德·B。所以这个真的把我逗乐了，好吧？好吧。因为我在接收谷歌提醒，伙计们。不是为了我自己。我会继续分享。贾雷德，我听说过这个，但你写信来真的把我逗乐了。所以贾雷德说，
Jarrett goes on to say, there's signs all over saying keep Kinsey.
And all I can think of is office ladies, Angela.
Are you secretly running for local office?
I think you'd be a great county auditor.
Wow, I did not know this.
Yeah, so I actually have had a few people say, hey, you might have a doppelkanger in Ohio.
Lady, years ago, I think a woman named Jenna Fisher committed a crime.
Oh, no.
有一个竞选斯塔克县审计员的女人名叫安吉拉·金西。伙计们，它的拼写完全一模一样。贾雷德接着说，到处都是写着“保持金西”的牌子。我能想到的只有办公室女士安吉拉。你是不是在秘密竞选地方公职？我觉得你会是一个很棒的县审计员。哇，我不知道这件事。是的，所以其实有几个人说过，嘿，你在俄亥俄州可能有一个双胞胎。女士，多年前，我想一个叫詹娜·费舍尔的女人犯了罪。哦，不。
Yeah, and I was getting like alerts.
Oh, my goodness.
Well, thanks, Jarrett, for writing in that tickled me.
And now our office question of the week.
It is from Anna B in Chickchester, UK, if I'm saying that right, Anna.
Anna says, hi, ladies.
I love the podcast.
I listen to you ladies all the time while driving, doing the dishes, falling asleep.
是的，我当时收到了警报。哦，天哪。好吧，谢谢贾雷德写信来，这把我逗乐了。现在是本周办公室问答环节。它来自英国奇切斯特的安娜·B，如果我没读错的话，安娜。安娜说，嗨，女士们。我喜欢这个播客。我经常在开车、洗碗、入睡时听你们的节目。
I've tried to get my husband, who's a big office fan, to listen to your podcast, but he can't
merge Angela Martin's cold and snarky attitude with real Angela's fun and upbeat personality.
Oh, no.
My question is, do you have a favorite and least favorite outfit you wore on the show?
Thanks.
Well, my favorite outfit popped into my mind immediately.
Okay.
What about you?
我曾试图让我的丈夫（他是一个狂热的《办公室》粉丝）听你们的播客，但他无法将安吉拉·马丁冷酷刻薄的态度与真实的安吉拉有趣开朗的性格联系起来。哦，不。我的问题是，你们有没有在剧中最喜欢和最讨厌的服装？谢谢。嗯，我最喜欢的服装立刻浮现在我的脑海里。好吧。你呢？
I think my favorite and least favorite happened on the same day.
Oh.
Same episode.
No way.
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Mine is from costume contest in season seven.
我觉得我最喜欢和最讨厌的发生在同一天。哦。同一集。不会吧。哦，我受不了。好吧。好吧。我的是来自第七季的服装比赛。
If you remember, my character dresses as a penguin.
It's so comfortable.
It was like wearing pajamas.
It was cozy.
I wasn't cold.
It was literally amazing.
Then I changed into a nurse, the nurse outfit.
I had this weird push-up bra plus those like cutlet things, you know, that like give you even more cleavage.
如果你还记得，我的角色打扮成一只企鹅。它太舒服了。就像穿着睡衣一样。很舒适。我不冷。简直太棒了。然後我换成了一套护士服，护士装。我穿了一件奇怪的聚拢胸罩，再加上那些像肉饼一样的东西，你知道的，能让你显得更有事业线的东西。
And I had like these weird thigh-high stockings and heels that were uncomfortable.
And I was like, this stinks.
I do not like this outfit.
I feel pushed and pulled and cinched and no thank you.
Well, it's very funny to me that your favorite and least favorite were in the same episode,
but also that it was a Halloween episode
because my favorite is from a Halloween episode.
Oh, can I guess?
我还穿着那种奇怪的过膝长袜和不舒服的高跟鞋。我当时就想，这太烂了。我一点也不喜欢这身衣服。我觉得自己被推来挤去、勒得紧紧的，谢谢不用了。好吧，我觉得很有趣的是，你最喜欢和最讨厌的居然在同一集里，而且那还是万圣节的一集，因为我最喜欢的也是来自万圣节的一集。哦，我能猜到吗？
Is it when you were olive oil?
No.
When I was the kangaroo, when I was super pregnant.
Wait, so basically the penguin and the kangaroo are our favorites.
Similar same.
Yes, exactly.
So comfy.
I was so comfortable.
是当你扮演橄榄油的时候吗？不是。当我扮演袋鼠的时候，当我超级怀孕的时候。等等，基本上企鹅和袋鼠是我们的最爱。异曲同工。是的，完全一样。超级舒服。我当时太舒服了。
It was glorious.
It was great.
And it was cute.
It was cute.
cute. You know, I loved everything about it. I thought the penguin was cute. So what was your least
favorite? Guys, I have to be honest. Okay. I really hated that outfit that I wore in Casual
Friday, the matching outfit that I wore with Phyllis that I found on the mannequin. So wait,
it's because it wasn't a jacket, it wasn't a sweater. It was like a shawl or something.
简直太棒了。太棒了。而且很可爱。很可爱。可爱。你知道的，我喜欢关于它的一切。我觉得企鹅很可爱。那么你最讨厌的是什么？伙计们，我必须说实话。好吧。我真的很讨厌我在《随性星期五》里穿的那件衣服，我和菲利斯穿的从人体模特身上找到的同款衣服。所以等等，那是因为它不是夹克，也不是毛衣。它就像是一条披肩之类的东西。
Listen, the shirt was fine.
I didn't mind the shirt.
But it was the weird purple half shawl cardigan thing.
And it just, I think it's like, it's funny.
You know how some things like over time they grow on you?
This is like the opposite of that over time.
Right.
Like every time I see it, it's gotten worse to me.
听着，衬衫是没问题的。我不介意那件衬衫。但那是那件奇怪的紫色半披肩开衫。而且我觉得，这很搞笑。你知道有些东西随着时间推移会让你越来越喜欢吗？这就像是那种随着时间推移完全相反的情况。对。就像每次我看到它，我都觉得它变得更糟了。
You're like, that sucks.
Like the first time I approved that costume.
I was like, yeah.
I like it. I believe it. It's good. It's cute. But like it has not aged well. It has aged worse.
You mean a sweater slash jacket weird shawl thing?
Yes. It just was like it wasn't even like a crop. It like came to like the mid brawline. It was yeah.
I'm going to have to shout that out as my least favorite. Well, there you go. Anna B and the United Kingdom. Thank you so much for writing in.
tell your husband to listen to Office Ladies.
你就会想，这太逊了。就像我第一次批准那套服装时。我当时想，对。我喜欢。我相信。挺好的。很可爱。但它没有保养老。它越变越差了。你是说那件毛衣夹克混合体的奇怪披肩吗？是的。它甚至都不像是短款的。它差不多齐胸罩线。是的。我必须把它当作我最讨厌的。好吧，就这样。英国的安娜·B。非常感谢你写信来。告诉你的丈夫去听《办公室Ladies》。
Tell him it's okay.
He's going to really like Angela Kinsey.
I hope.
Well, everyone, thank you so much for listening.
And thank you for sending us gifts and sending us your questions.
And a huge thank you to Robin Lynch for joining us today.
Yeah, we hope you guys have a great one.
We'll see you next week.
告诉他没关系。他会真的很喜欢安吉拉·金西的。我希望如此。好吧，大家，非常感谢你们的收听。谢谢你们给我们送礼物，给我们发送问题。还要特别感谢罗宾·林奇今天加入我们。是的，我们希望大家过得愉快。我们下周见。
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle, and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
到时候见。感谢收听《办公室Ladies》。《办公室Ladies》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期《办公室Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演奏的《Ruppertry》。